But what if we could stop an asteroid from
hitting in the first place?
Some of our brightest minds think we can.
How's that feel?
Good.
This film is about the threat of asteroids
and what we can actually do about that.
It seems such a perfect marriage, this subject with IMAX.
It's exciting, it's educational.
We show how scientists assess whether they're a threat,
what their orbits are,
what affects their orbits.
And then, if they are a threat, how we can mitigate them.
There are techniques,
like the kinetic impacter,
which would impact an asteroid
to slightly change its trajectory.
I've never been involved in a filming
where so much effort has been
made to be accurate.
We want to deliver a film that's exciting and cinematic,
and blows your mind,
but scientists and teachers walk out and say,
"Hey, they got it right."